[تصفيق]
مساء
الخير تعلمت بكليه الهندسه
المعماريه انه المشروع المحلول وظيفيا هو
المشروع
الناجح اما الاهتمام بالجمال على حساب
الوظيف فاكيد راح يعرض الفكره
للفشل الجمال شيء نسبي
ومتغير انا حاحكي عن نفسي لما كنت صغيره
كنت نحيفه كثير كان مقياس الجمال المراه
باللغه العاميه المعبا هلا لما كبرت
وتبيت صار مقياس
الجمال المراه النحيفه انا بالنسبه الي ما
حغير بلكي ه بيغيروا مقياس
الجبان اما اذا بدنا حلم مثالي فلازم يكون
عننا وظيفه زائد
جمال وليكون المبنى او المشروع خالد بدنا
نضيف لهدول الشغلات اللي قلنا وجود هويه
للمبنى نتيجه هالافكار طلقت بحياتي
العمليه وبلشت قيم نفسي وبلشت قيم الناس
اللي
قدامي بس كنت اتساءل دوما شو هو سر ازياد
اهتمام شبابنا بالشكل على حساب
المضمون
لما قررت انا ومجموعه من الاصدقاء انشاء
مدرسه كان همنا الاول تطوير عقول الناشئين
وجعلهم يخوضوا غمار الحياه
بنجاح ومن اول هالسنه طلبت من طلاب طلبت
من طلاب المرحله الثانويه قيام بدراسات
معمقه وميدانيه حول هذا الموضوع لانه هن
اقدر منا على رؤيه مشاكلهم وعلى ايجاد
الحلول
الها كنت دائما اضرب للطلاب
مثل
انه نحن عننا ببلادنا اللي بيرمي طعام او
شراب بيعتبر جاحد به
النعمه بس يا ترى النعمه هي بس طعام وشراب
ولا اي شيء منحنا اياه ربنا وميزنا فيه
يعني انا لما بكون عندي عقل وعندي فكر
وبسته فيهم وما بستفيد منهم فكاني انا عم
برمي عقلي او عم ادوس
عليه الطلاب شافوا انه اهم سبب لانه نهتم
بمظهرنا هو التربيه اللي عم تربها ووسائل
الترفيه بتفكروا لما بجيب الالعاب
لاطفالنا بفكر يا ترى قبل ليش عم نجيب
هاللعبه وهل هاللعبه عم تسهم بنمو الاطفال
ولا لا هلا كل واحد منكم يفكر باخر ثلاث
لعب جابها
لاولاده اكيد كثير منكم فكر بباربي انا حا
اعطي مثال عن
باربي هلا باربي هي نموذج لفتاه مكتمله
الانوثه
جسمها ابعاده غير واقعيه بتسكن
لحالها باربي عندها خزانه مليانه
ثياب باربي عندها كلب عندها حصان عندها
بيت وعندها صديق اسمه
كين هون هبوا العرب طبعا الحمد لله كين
ليهب بشانه هبوا العرب
وتوحدوا بدهم يردوا على باربي فلقوا انه
احسن ش يردوا عليها بالنسخه المعربه
فلا فلا لها نفس جسم
باربي بس وعندها خزانه مليانه بالقوا يعني
ما يفكروا حدا احسن من
حدا بس فله ساكنه مع عيلتها ومع اخواتها
الصغار الشركه هلا عم تصنع اخ كبير لفله
على اساس هو يعني ليحميها انا حسب ظني
ليحكمها يعني لانه مو ناقصه فله اكثر من
هيك وفله ما فيها غير ما فيها تسوق سياره
وما فيها تكون الا طبيبه او معلمه بينما
باربي فيها تكون رائده فضاء فيها تكون
سيده اعمال وحتى كمان فيها
تكون
اميره وانا لما برفض باربي برفض مع
فله لانه فله مو هي الحل المثالي بالعكس
هي فله هي اللي انحرمت جزء من حريتها بس
اخذت مظهر
باربي والبنات لما بيقلدوا باربي بلبسهم
وح يتهم العاليه يعني بيطلعوا مثل السيده
القصيره يعني بالعام نحن بنقول نص
مره حاحكي قصه صارت عن بنتي وقت كانت
صغيره اجت مره سالتني بعد ما زارت رفيقتها
ليش رفيقتي ب خزانتها في في ملابس ضعف
الملابس اللي ب
خزانتي فكرت كيف بدي
اجاوبها وانبسطت بعدين لقيت جواب قلت له
رفيقتك عندها نفس عدد الكتب اللي بمكتبتي
حسيتها بلشت ترجع ثقتها بنفسها قالت لي
رفيقتي اصلا ما عندها
مكتبه هون علمت بنتي انه ما نقارن بغيرنا
وانه لكل واحد بهالحياه
اولوياته ما بظن انا غلطت مع بنتي لانه
هلا بنتي عندها عندها بنت عمرها سنتين
بلشت عاملت لها مكتبه وعندها تقريبا
مجموعه من
القصف اذا بدي احكي عن العاب الصبيان
فاكيد راح احكي على العاب الكترونيه لانه
80% من العاب الصبيان هي العاب الكترونيه
و 80% من الالعاب الالكترونيه هي العاب
عنف دماء قتال هذا الشيء بخليهم عدوانيين
منعزلين مستغرقين كليا ناسين كل شيء
حواليهم انا بتذكر وقت كان ابني صغير بشوف
هلا صورته قدامي عم يصف الحيوانات
بحط بحط الحيوانات الاليف على طرف المتوحش
على طرف مره ثانيه بصف الاس اسرع ف الابطا
مره الاكبر فال الاصغر او عم يلعب بالليجو
ويعمل بيت او سياره طبعا انتم ما بيخفى
عليكم هالشغلات قديش فيها من عم تنمي
نواحي الفكريه وحتى الحسيه عنده ولما
كبروا اولادي انضموا لفرق
رياضيه فكان عززت الحياه الاجتماعيه عندهم
فكانوا يفرحوا مع بعض وحزنوا مع بعض بينما
اطفال يوم ما في شيء بيهمهم من الرياضه
الا يلي بكبر عضلاتهم او بحسر شكل
جسمهم انا حتى بفكر شو شو الاهميه للرياضه
بحياتهم اذا كانوا عن طريق هال الاجهزه
الالكترونيه بيقدروا يعملوا فريق وبيقدر
يجيبوا اللاعبين يسموهم باسمائهم ويقدروا
يفوزوا ايمتى ما بدهم وبشعر انه هذا الزر
الصغير يلي بين ايدهم بحرك العالم كله من
حولهم شو حاجتهم هم ليتحرك حول
العالم
اما اذا بدي احكي عن المطالعه كوسيله
للتربيه فانا بفضل ما احكي لانه هذا الجيل
مستحيل يفكر بالقرا اذا كان جيلنا اللي ما
كان في كل هال الاجهزه ما كان يقرا كيف
بدي اطلب من ابني انه يقرا انا بتذكر وقت
كنت اسال رفقاتي ليش ما بتقر كان الجواب
جاهز مباشره بتمنى بس ما عندي
وقت هذول نفسهم اللي متمنيين يعني ح
اسميهم كنت شوف النساء منهم طبعا على
الاغلب ممكن يقضوا يومين ليحضروا حالهم
اذا عندهم روحه عم يضبطوا حالهم بيتمكيجوا
اما الباقي فقعد بالقهاوي حاملين
اراجيل بين كل سحبه وسحبه في صفنه مدتها
شي خمس دقائق وصفنه هيك بالمجهول يعني
بتحس حالك صغير قدام هالقد مغه اللي عم
[تصفيق]
تارجل يمكن الارجيله سببها انه نحن عننا
اكتئاب عننا هروب من الواقع عننا عقد نقص
بس السبب الثاني اللي لقوا الاولاد هو سبب
لحتى نهتم بالمظهر هو عقد النقص نحن من
وقت ما بولد بحمل
ختم جواتنا مكتوب عليه شعوب العالم الثالث
وهذا الختم ما فينا نغيره ان شاء الله
احفاد احفادنا يقدروا
يغيروه لما بشوف حالنا عالم ثالث اجباري
بدنا نحاول نلحق الامم المتقدمه شو اسهل
واسرع طريقه هي طريقه الحياه او طريقه
المعيشه او اللباس طبعا
وبالتالي اكثر الناس بحاولوا يقلدوا الغرب
بلباسهم لانه اذا بدنا نقلدهم بالتطور
العلمي والمعرفي هذا بيتطلب منا سنوات
طويله وعمل
جبار فلقوا الحل الاسرع والاسهل انه
يقلدوه هو
الشكل نحن لما كنا باوج
حضارتنا كان الغرب يتعلم اللغه العربيه
وكانوا يترجموا مؤلفات لتكون اساسا ل
نهضتهم هلا المثقفين فينا عم يتعلموا
اللغه الاجنبيه وهذا شيء كثير ايجابي وانا
بشجع
عليه بس المشكله انه اللي شفته من خلال
عملي بمجال التعليم انه الاهل عم يهتموا
اكثر بتعليم اولادهم اللكنه اهم من اللغه
يعني
الاكسنت يعني بيجوا الاهل بقوللك ها
الاكسنت بدي تمام تمام تكون مثل اللغه
الفلانيه طيب هلا الاجنبي وقت بيحكي لغتنا
هل بحكيها بلفس كلتنا اكيد لا ونحن بشجعه
ونبسط فيه حتى الفرنسي وقت بيحكي
الانجليزي بكيها بلكنت وهو فخور اما نحن
ممكن نبطل نحكي اذا ماا متاكدين انه
اللكنه تبعنا 100% مثل اصحاب اللغه
نفسها
المشكله انه كمان صار من مظاهر الترف
والتقدم خلط اللغات مع بعضها يعني بحكي
عربي على فرنسي على انجليزي ثلاث لغات مع
بعض بحب انه نسمع تسجيل لفتاه عم تحكي مع
رفيقتها الو لك هاي
بونجور سفا
وانت
وي اوكي انا بجي بس بدي اروح قبل شوبين
على المول بدي اجيب شو شايفته و خلص ل
كان
ماشي تشاو
تشاو هلا خلال 25 ثانيه حكيت اربع
لغات اخر وحده اسباني بس في لغه ما عرفتها
بونجور واكيت هدول ما بعرف باي
لغه والاسوا لغه التشات بقى يلي
بيكتبوا اللغه العربيه بحروف انجليزيه انا
ما ح احكي عنها لانه فعلا ما بفهم شي منها
كلمه بدي اقولها انه خسارتنا للغتنا هي
خسارتنا لجزء من
هويتنا ما بعرف اذا كنا عن طريق هال
اللغات عم نقلد مقدمات البرامج او شيء
ثاني لانه لقوا طلابنا انه الوسيله
الثالثه او السبب الثالث للاهتمام بالمظهر
هو وسائل
الاعلام اكثر شيء بثر بالعالم كله هلا هو
وسائل الاعلام وما ح احكي عن وسائل
الاعلام الالكتروني لانه يمكن بده
يعني حلقه كامله له وهو اكثر مؤثر بالعالم
انا حاحكي
عن الجهاز التلفزيون يلي هو محور اجتماع
الاسره مساء اذا كان في كهرباء
طبعا وانا بستغرب انه ليش يعني اكثر
البرامج شعبيه واكثر الناس شهره هن الناس
اللي بيشاركوا ببرامج بتعتمد على
الشكل وبتعتمد على المظهر وهي هي بتكون
بيكون المشارك فيها اكثر شهره بالعالم
العربي كله طيب ما سالتوا حالكم وين
البرامج
الثقافيه ليش ما في برامج ثقافيه حدا
بذكركم هلا برنامج ثقافي مشهور عمي عراض
ما في ليش ما يكون المتسابق الاكثر ثقافه
له نفس هال الشهره هي خطه
مدروسه بما انه لي علاقه بالاطفال الصغار
فيني احكي عن افلام كرتون افلام كرتون على
ايام قبل
كانت ماخوذه من قصص عالميه مبسطه للاطفال
فيها براءه فيها عزوبه فيها خيال واذا بدي
احكي عن افلام كرتون اكيد ما حانسى توم
وجيري توم وجيري انا بالنسبه لي عمل في
تحريك للخيال في متعه في فكاهه والاهم في
حس موسيقي عالي يعني بكفي نظف اذاننا من
هالموسيقى الهابطه ووصلنا موسيقى راقيه
بطريقه غير مباشره هلا اولادنا عم يشوفوا
اما مخلوقات فضائيه واما مخلوقات
مشوهه فما لازم نستغرب ابدا لما بنلاقي
انه احلامنا بالليل تحولت من احلام دراميه
لاحلام من فئه
الاكشن يمكن هي الاسره والقعده مع
الاسره هي سبب المجتمع تبعنا مجتمعنا
مجتمع مغلق ولقوا طلابنا انه السبب الرابع
لنهتم بالمظهر هو هذا المجتمع المغلق
المجتمع المغلق له ايجابيات كثير واهم
ايجابيات الترابط الاسري بتشوف الحياه
اكثر حميميه واكثر
جمال بس هذا المجتمع له سلبيات كثير لانه
تركنا حرين ونعيش بحريه بس ضمن جدران
بيبنيها هو جدران من عادات وتقاليد يمكن
تكون قسم منها بالي
ومنتهي بس مطلوب منا نعيش داخله واي واحد
بفكر يطلع خارج ه الجدران يعتبر شخص منبوز
من
المجتمع في مثل بقول شامي كل ما تشتهي
والبوس ما يليق بالناس يعني نحن بدنا نظل
نفكر بالناس حتى ونا
نلبس والمشكله انه كثير قلال من اللي بكون
عندهم الشجاعه انه يتحدوا هذا
المجتمع بالاخير بيمشوا معه برفوا المجتمع
بتيار بصيروا جزء منه والمجتمع ما بشوف
عيوبه لانه هو ربي معه وعاش
معه وكل الكبار بنعرف نحن انه هم صاروا
جزء من هالمجتمع وبشوف كل شيء فيه هو شيء
ايجابي هذا ايمان مطلق بهذا المجتمع يلي
هو فيه كثير من
السلبيات في عندي
سؤال سالته للطلاب انه هل المجتمع هو بثر
فينا ولا نحن اللي بثر
بالمجتمع طلابنا لقوا ان المجتمع هو اللي
عم ياثر فينا وخاصه
بسلبياته وقرر
يغير بس تغير واحد يخترق جدران مجتمع صعب
كثير فقرروا سوا مع بعض يغيروا الافكار
اللي ضوها
بالمجتمع وبلش يشكلوا فرق فرق لكثير شغلات
فريق بيهتم بالمسرح والدراما
والموسيقى فريق بمثلوا طلاب وبيكونوا ههم
صله وصل بينهم وبين
الاداره فريق يعني انا ما ح احكي عن هذا
فريق بدي احكي عن طالب وقف من الاوائل
وقال انا بدي اعلم رفقاتي المواد اللي انا
شاطر فيها لانه انا الدراسه مو بس انه انا
اطلع اولي انا بدي كل رفقاتي اوائل هلا
انا بالبدايه حسيت انه هيك عنده حماس يعني
مبدئي بس هلا اللي عم اشوفه بكل اوقات
الفراغ كل مجموعه قاعدين مع بعض و عم يعلم
كل واحد الشاطب مادي عم يعلم
رفقاته حتى في عننا دروس واحد عم يعلم
رفقاته كيف يدخلوا على كيف يعملوا مواقع
وكيف
يبرمج اهم شيء الفريق يلي يلي ساعدنا
بهالمده واللي حب يسمي حاله فريق مظهر
وجوهر هذا الفريق او الفرق كلها اذا بكون
عملوا محاضرات لرفقاتكم الاصغر
ركزوا على طلب العلم على حب اللغه العربيه
على اهتمام بمضمون اكثر من
مظهرهم انا اللي استغربته واللي بهرني انه
هذا العمر الطلاب بعتقد ما بحبوا يحملوا
مسؤوليات بس انا اللي شفته بالواقع انه هم
عم يخترعوا مسؤوليات
ليحملها انا سعيده كثير بهدول الفرق وحاسه
انه حيكونوا نواه لفكر جديد بالمجتمع هن
كانوا عم يشتغلوا على الاصغر وبعدين كانوا
يرجعوا على البيت يحكوا لاهلهم شو عملوا
لينقلوا بصوره غير مباشره حتى لاهلهم
الافكار اللي هن حابينها وعندهم هدف
مستقبلي انه يتواصلوا مع طلاب الجامعه
اللي تخرجوا قبلهم لينشروا افكارهم
بالجامعه وبالمناسبه هن عندهم حملوني
رساله للجامعات انه الجامعات مو بس تاخذ
بعين الاعتبار الدخول الى العلامه وانما
تاخذ كمان قديش عمل فرد تطوير مجتمعه
وهذا موجود باغلب بلاد
العالم بالنهايه انا بدي احيي هفرق اللي
تشكلت بمدرستنا بدي احيي فريق مظهر وجوهر
والاساتذه اللي
ساندوه ولانه فريق مظهر وجوهر شاف انه
اهتمامنا بمظهرنا كافي حبوا يحملوا شعار
ايها الشباب اقلوا جوهرك
شكرا
ه